hello everyone we've already seen one
game from the round 6 of the 2018 bill
chess festival and momager offs a nice
victory against young Nico so why not
check out another one it's Peter Svidler
from against Maxine by Sheila Grove and
it's very interesting although it's a
it's quite an online how you know
appearing Lee
Maxine breaks opening principles by
moving the same same piece numerous
times in the opening so before we check
out the game I would have a nice photo
challenge let's check it out who is this
person in the photo here and I will give
you a little hint as recently he is the
new editor in chief of the American
chess magazine so best of luck to
everyone and we also do have a photo of
this encounter there you have it we were
preparing to make his first move so
let's see what was Villiers first move
let's check it out as fiddler opens with
c4 so he goes for the English opening we
have c5 Knight to f3 Knight to f6 and
the Knight to c3 now d5 and I always
enjoy any opening where you can push d5
and you feel good about yourself and not
like the Scandinavian sometimes I do
feel play the Scandinavian although I
don't feel very good about myself when I
put d5 on the first move although here
it seems a perfectly reasonable C captor
Sun d5 Knight captures on d5 you could
capture with the knight here as well but
Daniels oversimplify the position and
this only helps the black equalize C
capture Sun d5 Knight captures on d5 and
now II for and okay although you can
capture the knight on c3 Maxime goes for
a different approach he goes nice to be
four so already planning Knights to d3
check and the PS wheeler isn't really
all that interested in this he simply
continues developing Bishop to c4 we
have nice the d3 check and now although
you could play King to f1 simply getting
out of the way
still replace it the best move King to
e2 attacking amok seems Knight and
forcing it to move as now the knight is
attacked twice
nice to f4 check you could capture the
bishop but the checking the King is
better Knight to f4 check we have King
to f1
and now comes night the e6 you do have
to move the night if you try and
continue developing with something like
ecigs then d4 comes with tempo as the
night is under attack and then after
captures captures captures captures your
night is still under attack you do have
to move it or protect it better is to
move it but then comes nice to be 5
threatening nice to see 7 to win the
rook and after black stops this with
knife to a6 you can simply continue
developing and here white would have a
big big early lead in development and
also black would have a funny night on
a6 so this would be excellent for white
so instead after King f1 first night to
e6 putting the knight back
we have d3 nights the c6 and now as you
can see this Knight is kind of blocking
blacks development he can't really move
this point here so the most reasonable
idea to presume is that black will play
g6 and try to feel care to the bishop
and Castle kingside
so Svidler prepares for this he plays h4
preparing to meet the g6 with h5 maxime
doesn't mind
we have g6 h5 and Bishop to g7 simply
continuing development it's almost never
a good idea to play something like H
captures H captures and exchange this as
you haven't really achieved anything
black will simply play but should be 7
Queen b6 maybe even Castle queenside so
if anything you've only helped to black
so after Bishop to g7 we have Bishop to
e3 and now Knight the d4 we have h6
pushing the bishop either to f8 or or f6
Bishop to f6 is played and now comes
Knight to d5 Bishop to g4 Maxine
continues developing developing the
Knight captures and f6 pawn captures on
f6 and now Bishop captures on d4 Knight
captures on d4 and Dena comes Queen to
a4 check we have Queen to d7 blocking
you could block with the knight bring
the knight back or you could even block
with the bishop but as all of these
pieces are on very nice squares I Maxime
decides to play Queen to d7 we have
Queen captures the bishop captures and
now comes the Knights captures on d4 C
capture some before and this appears to
be the critical moment of the game I
haven't
seen the live coverage so I haven't seen
if there was an interview after the game
between Spiller and Maxine if there was
you know feel free to share in the
comments what happened here here white
should play something like kinky too
prepared to bring this rook into the
game or okay if for some reason sweedler
decided that he will bring the rook into
the game via the h-file that's a
different story or rook to c1 preparing
to bring the other rook into the game
but instead he played d5 it seems like a
reasonable move as after you capture of
course rook to e1 is coming but it seems
that he didn't calculate everything
precisely here Maxine captured we have
rook to e1 as planned f6 defending the
e5 pawn and now f4 and okay d5 pawn is
pinned all is well here but here comes
rope to f8 and okay now you can't win
the pawn back which captures captures
because now there is a discovered to
check here and after we move the King
rope to f5 will actually defend this
pawn so Maxine would actually just be up
upon here so I have to rope to a fate
first King to g1 and now comes King to
e7
we have pawn captures and here comes a
move that s wither most likely missed
when he decided to pull the pond to e5
here Maxine does not capture back rather
he pushes f5 so the material on the
board is equal but as you can see there
is this the matter of this ePHI pawn
here and okay rook to h4 silver tries to
bring the rook into the game via an
attack against the d4 pawn and now f4
blocking and pushing at the pawn rook to
e4 now attacking the d4 pawn with this
rook and now comes g5 attacking the h4
rook rook to h5 and now comes Rock to f5
offering rook captures and d4 in
exchange for rook captures on e5 and
although this isn't something you would
very much enjoy doing it's probably the
best course of action force wiggler
for example rook captures rook captures
and after rook d5 offering an exchange
captures captures and now comes King to
f6 and here is the problem for white a
white can't really activate the rook on
h5 after Bishop captures rook b8
attacking the bishop bishop
moves the black can even exchange the
light square bishop for example captures
captures and after white prevents this
rook from capturing unbe - for example
v3 we have looked to see it the rook
will now infiltrate White's position and
the district is still stuck on h5 unable
to enter the game so a much better
position for black so although it seems
like just the trade of pawns not really
so here Villiers tries g4 but as you see
in the game it's not all that much
better F capture son g3 was played we
have looked to g4 now either preparing
to capture the the g3 point or the g5
phone as the g5 phone is also attacked
twice but there is a move that wins the
game here unfortunately for first Hitler
so feel free to pause the video here and
try to find this very nice idea
i'm maxeen played to win this game so i
will give it a couple of seconds as
usual if you want to decide whether to
do it or not for those of you who were
able to do it you know the most obvious
answer is most most often the most
simple one simply bring your last
inactive piece into the game rook a to
f8 and now it's simply a lost position
for white as you can see how powerful
this rook and the other rook are on the
F file here is whatever you play for
example if you play something like rook
captures and g3 you get rook rook f1
check King moves
now comes the bishop to c6 check and
after King moves simply Bishop to f3 and
this rock is strapped
black is easily winning this on the
other hand if after rook a to f8 you
play something like rook G captures on
g5 again you get rook to f1 check King
moves rope to f2 check the king captures
and g3 and now rook to f3 check King has
to move and now rook to h3 and this is
checkmate so spoiler tried the third
idea rook H captures on g5 here maxime
played rook to f1 check we have King to
g2 and after Bishop to c6 Peter Svidler
resigned the game unmoved 31 why did you
resign because he's either loose
material or he will face one of the
worst windmills ever seen in a chess
game for example you could play rookie
for simply offer an exchange and then
you're done the exchange you're just
losing the game
you could try rook at English three but
after King to h3 it's pretty much the
same as if you just capture the point as
the rook will force you to capture the
point
so King captures so instead after Bishop
to c6 you're most likely viable option
is actually King captor son g3 but this
runs into into a terrible terrible
windmill hence I thought of this title
Peter against the windmills I do hope
you enjoy that because look to g1 check
now what do you play here King to h2 it
doesn't really matter
rook to h1 check King has to move back
and now the other rook comes to f3 this
comes with check and the king can only
go to one square and that is came to g2
and now you can see wherever this rook
moves it's gonna be you know not not
very enjoyable for for poor Peter but
okay here for example rookie after son
d3 it's a discovered check King has to
move and now simply rook to d2 check
King has to move back
King g3 now comes rook to g2 check once
again kinga for Luke to f2 check King
has to move back King g3 Malcolm's rook
to f3 check once again and after King to
g2 you once again forced the White King
back on g2 and now you can play rook to
b3 check after the King moves can you
have two now you capture the b2 point
after the King moves you simply repeat
rubgy to check King moves rook F to
check King G 3 root 2 F 3 check and once
again you have forced the King onto the
light square that is g2 King g2 and only
now after you captured a couple of
points do you play rook the c3 and now
it's all over as you can really capture
the bishop on c4 King has to move and
now comes rook captures in c4 you just
want two points and the bishop it's all
over for white so of course you will not
allow something like this but it's
definitely a beautiful windmill and I I
really do hope you enjoyed it
so after King G 2 after Bishop to c6 was
played this game which check and like
we've said it was in this position that
resigned the game if by any chance you
haven't seen my previous video here are
the final standings after round six so
there you have it
mama D out of chakra with four and a
half point out of six a magnus carlsen
with four out of six s he is the only
player who is unable to beat Gary
goddess Nico
then Peter Svidler three out of six
after losing the game to Maxine never
heard of it three out of six Maxine
Bashir three out of six and Nico your
goddess only 1/2 point out of six but
like we've said those half a point came
from drawing a game with the world
champion Magnus Carlsen so yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it and I
do hope you're enjoying the coverage of
the Beals tournament so far I would like
to thank Tyler crane
Francesco Paiva a Jose Iglesias Jovi
Anya Jovi not so Roberto Aiello and the
Douglas rice for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here think of for
watching and I will see you soon with
round 12 of the palma de mallorca
inter-zonal tournament of 1970 and the
Bobby Fischer story thank you all and
I'll see you soon